clinical trials have shown the medical
circumcision that protects men from
infection yet you're doing a
circumcision study wide before you can
put on a biomedical intervention on to a
community you have to know what the
community does and why it does it how it
does it but I thought we make up in
Greenland passing this luckily he was
cut by his older brother and then while
doing that or when they when he did that
he passed on the scale on to him
making mention of booze no mm perhaps he
fought number when we can't stop now
but in making cutting no one
we found incredibly diverse practices
men were doing dorsal slits they were
doing cowboy slits they were doing all
these kinds of slips that are not a
force to come for circumcision men were
also putting inserts into their penis
men were also putting other substances
into their penises to make them bigger
Longer whatever and I think that was
really important because you have to
understand both the clinical and the
social implications of those practices
before you could even think about
another intervention on top you do the
cut or long how do you do the cut skin
suppose Mila cotton 15 plop I'm already
15 pleurisy
so bamboo to embark 15 10 how old are
the boys generally what's the age 8 8
then is it painful no mosquito bite we
asked the community what do they think
about this kind of practice in terms of
a medical male circumcision program and
we found a really big difference men
were for it men thought it would be
great
women you know working from their own
life history said we think that will
give men license to have more sex have
more partners some women thought it
would rape more do women like when men
are cut yeah
why why do they care why do they liked
it because time if I'm making low cut
because skinning we'll see left side now
I was in Brazil even tell Miriam to play
skinless I am finally Morris idea phylum
side balm air in a more like him what
age do boys start having sex here
usually
it is well in the end time was no more
cutting me stop commands finish maybe
two or three months now
Silver Dollar
sometime we'll be taking more loss seek
seek sample I am all same custom grow
more Latinos and make him on strong
sometime motion go sycophant Isola
have you seen infections before after a
cutting
and so we spent a long time maybe 18
months collecting data from the four
regions of the country we did the
Eastern Highlands we went out to West
New Britain which has traditional
circumcision we went to the East Sea
Peak and we went to Port Moresby and put
Mosby's a melting pot really of the
whole country and we did a mathematical
model what what impact male circumcision
could have on the epidemic compare that
to what actually improving access to
treatment would have on the epidemic and
I think it's cited with actually
treatment access would be a much better
use of money